exactly once white's pawn recaptures
that bishop
black's queen will jump in with check
white's pawns are disappearing the
shelter around the white king is
gone and it's going to be checkmate in a
few more moves
wow will he resign no well he's made a
move
he's defending in a rather unique way
the rook has uh
managed to snake its way from the left
to the right
but okay it's it's going to be all over
yup okay the bishop just retreats white
uh magnus keeping things simple there
were other deadlier ways of finishing
off this game but he wants to play
safety first chess he trades the bishop
as soon as white recaptures his rook
will disappear magnus wins
oh look at that celebration from magnus
carlsen he is the winner of an
extremely tense quota final match
against hikaru nakamura who has played
fantastically but unfortunately
we're losing hikaru nakamura now he is
out magnus carlsen is through
to the semi-finals and look how happy he
is i know it's
a great great to see